-Molly, thanks so much for
coming, being here in person!
-Oh, my God. I love it.
-I love that you're here.
I talk to you
whenever I get a chance,
and I don't want to bother you
on social media because --
I follow you on Instagram.
Good follow, by the way.
-Whoo!
-And you really are fun.
Yesterday you had a catwalk-off,
of which outfit you should wear.
And it just made me laugh.
I loved it.
It was like -- It was --
You called yourself --
"Good Sandy or Bad Sandy."
-Oh, yeah.
-And I was like, "Yeah."
I would go for Bad Sandy.
I like Bad Sandy.
-Mmm. Good. I like that.
-Yeah, because there's
a little mysterious to --
-Leather jacket
or no leather jacket?
-Yeah, yeah. It was good.
-Aw. Thanks, Jimmy.
-But I don't want to like
too much and comment too much
because I'd be like,
"I'm not stalking you."
I just enjoy you, and I just go
like, "Oh, I love that."
'Cause it's so funny
and interesting.
You posted something
the other day.
-Oh, yeah.
-This is from --
@theofficialsuperstar
is the Instagram.
-Ooh.
-And this is it right here.
This is Sally O'Malley
with Betty O'Malley.
-Yeah!
-I mean, come on.
-[ Laughter ]
-With Betty O'Malley.
-Wait. Explain Betty O'Malley.
-Betty O'Malley.
Well, what happened was --
I had to do -- For my
daughter's school fundraiser,
they asked me
to do Sally O'Malley.
And I was like, "Yeah, but I
don't really have the costume."
It's in -- You know, it's in,
like, some storage place
or in the -- But anyhow,
I was able to get the costume
from Dale Richards.
-No way.
From "Saturday Night Live."
-I did. So he sent it to me.
And then I had it for
like 24 hours in my house
before I went to do this remote,
you know, show for my school.
So I put the costume on
and I told my husband --
I was like,
"We should take pictures."
And I wanted to take pictures
with the kids.
Because when I did
the character, it was before
I was married or had children,
so I just did, like,
a photo shoot around my house
as the character.
-How are the kids?
-Stella and Nolan.
And, yeah, they're great.
We just took the kids to Hawaii
with all --
They got to bring their friends,
and it was so much fun.
-But the dog --
Does the dog have wigs or --
That was my --
-Yeah.
-That's not natural, right?
That's not natural hair?
-That's not natural.
Yeah, she does have little --
I like putting little wigs
on her.
Like, I went to a pet store.
I like the close-up shot.
Yes!
That's...
[ Laughter ]
She's so cute.
-I love it!
-Yeah, isn't it sweet?
-Look at how cute --
-When did you get Betty?
-Betty. We got her --
She's a little rescue dog,
and we have another dog
named Cinnamon.
And, ohh. They add so much joy
to the house.
Isn't she cute?
-There was also a video
that you posted.
If you ever --
If you're in a bad mood,
just go to this Instagram --
@theofficialsuperstar.
Here's Betty going for a swim.
-Oh, my gosh.
I got to see this.
[ Laughter ]
Cinnamon with her curlers.
And that's Cinnamon. Ohh! Yes!
-Good swimmer.
-Yes, she's a good swimmer.
They're stars!
-Yeah, she is a star.
I heard that Nick Jonas got you
on Instagram. Is that true?
-Oh, yeah. Nick Jonas.
That was so funny.
I was in Park City, Utah,
with my manager, Steven Levy,
and we met Nick Jonas
and his dear friend Dave O.
And it was, like, a bar
in Park City, Utah.
And they got me
to join Instagram at the bar.
-What?
They just took a picture and --
-Well, we just started talking,
and Nick Jonas was so nice.
And Nick Jonas and I
share the same birthday.
And Dave O was like,
"You got to be on Instagram!"
So just at the bar
he was like --
You know, I think he thought
of @theofficialsuperstar.
And Nick Jonas was like,
"Yeah, do it.
I'll be the first one
to like your..."
So, that was Nick Jonas
and Dave O.
Isn't that wild?
-Wow.
-And then this was so funny.
Nick Jonas DM'd me --
This was like a year ago
or whatever.
He DM'd me and he's like,
"Oh, I have a question for you."
And so I told my daughter,
Stella, and I was like,
"Oh, my God.
Nick Jonas, you know, DM'd me."
And I responded back
with, like, a heart and then --
By accident,
I didn't mean to do that.
And then I was like, "O, my God.
I'm so embarrassed.
I put a heart. Like,
I'm acting like a teenage girl!"
She was like, "You can erase it.
You can erase it."
So I, like, erased it...
I was like, "That's so dorky."
-I know, dude.
I send Nick Jonas hearts, too.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah. Of course.
It's Nick Jonas.
-You guys, what I want to say
I love about Jimmy
is Jimmy is the silliest --
has the silliest sense of humor.
And I miss your --
how much you make me laugh.
You're very silly.
-Oh, my God.
We talk about it every time
on the show.
You know what I was thinking
of doing this time?
But I'm not ready for it
this time. I'm unprepared.
-What?
-I wanted to have our cry-off.
-Oh, my God. Whoa. Okay.
-I wanted to see if we --
Not now. I can't do it now.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a really good idea.
-But it's an interesting game,
and I got to be in the zone.
I got to be in the zone.
-You have to be in the zone.
I'll do it. Okay. Great.
-Next time?
-Next time. I'm scared.
Well, if we did it --
You want to do it now?
-Now?
-Oh, my God. I am so scared.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is not planned.
-All right.
-[Bleep]. I'm scared.
-All right. Can you --
All right. Wait.
I'll look in the camera.
-This is pressure.
-I know.
-So, wait. Okay.
-Can you do it?
-I mean, I'll try.
Where do I look?
-You look in camera one.
-Camera one.
Okay, but give us time.
[ Laughter ]
Music?
[ Audience awws ]
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-I was really close.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-You are unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh!
All right. Stop. No, no. Wait.
Oh, no. You're in -- Oh, no.
-[ Sighs ]
-She's in the zone.
-[ Sobs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's fake. It's fake!
-Dude, that was great, though.
-I had a moment
where I was like,
"This is so sweet, like,
being with an audience."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was nice.
I love you, bud.
-I don't know.
And, like, Questlove.
And I just --
I actually am like --
It's so sweet
being back with people.
And I love you, Jimmy.
Seriously.
-Me too...
Actually, if you zoom in,
I'm there.
You did. You got me there.
-Okay, good.
-If you zoom in, I'm there.
-Yes!
-You got me. You got me good.
-Okay, good. I got you!
What if we just got really --
What if we just, like,
turned the whole show around
and we were just really dark?
And I was like,
"Remember when I called you?"
And we just cry.
-We have so many fun things
to talk about.
You have two shows on HBO Max.
-Okay, yes, yes, yes.
Fun things, yes.
-You have "White Lotus"
I want to talk about.
-Yes!
-And we have "The Other Two."
I want to talk more with Molly
Shannon when we come back.